hi
my name is esther and i'm going to tell
you about the experimental design
assistant
an interactive web-based tool to provide
bespoke feedback on experimental plans
from vivo studies
so i work for the nc three hours and i'm
just going to give you a bit of a
background about us as an organization
so we are the national center for the
replacement refinement and reduction of
animals in research
we're an independent scientific
organization funded by the uk government
we were established in 2004 we lead on
the discovery and application of new
technologies and approaches to replace
reduce and refine the use of animals in
research which is traditionally known as
the three hours
and partnership is really key to
everything that we do and we work with
scientists and organisations across the
biosciences sectors
including universities other funders
pharmaceutical chemical and consumer
products industries
as well as regulators most of our budget
goes towards funding research and we are
the main funder of three hours research
in the uk
but we also have in-house programs led
by scientists in the office
and one of these programs is the
experimental design program which
i work on our experimental design
program
addresses concerns around the
reproducibility of biomedical research
and these are concerns which have also
been identified by others
so this slide shows a report from the
academy of medical sciences
and they did this in collaboration with
the bbsrc medical research council and
the welcome trust and they looked at
improving research practice
and they were looking at potential
causes for reproducibility and
reliability issues in biomedical
research
and they identified six causes and i'll
just quickly go over them
one was emitting null results so this is
also known as publication bias
when scientists or journals decide not
to publish studies unless the results
are statistically significant
data dredging also known as p hacking so
this involves repeatedly searching a
data set or trying alternative analyses
until a significant result is found
weak experimental design so a study may
have one or more methodological flaws
that mean it's unlikely to produce
reliable or valid results
underpowered studies so statistical
power is the probability that the
analysis will detect an effect of a
pre-specified size if that effect exists
an underpowered study is too small to
reliably indicate whether or not that
effect exists
and then there are things like errors
technical errors that may result within
a study so misidentified reagents or
computational errors
and then under specified methods so
study may be really robust
but if its methods are not shared with
other scientists in enough detail then
others can't precisely replicate it so
that's underspecified
and the eda which i'll be introducing
you to shortly can help you avoid data
dredging
can make your experimental design
stronger and help you avoid an
underpowered study
so these two papers on this slide have
also really highlighted reproducibility
issues and they seem to have given the
reproducibility movement a lot of
momentum
so these papers describe findings of
in-house validation projects from bayer
and amgen so before embarking on new
translational efforts
most pharmaceutical companies routinely
try to reproduce in-house
interesting data from the published
scientific literature
and these validation studies can take
six to twelve months
but the issue is that in the majority of
cases the in-house data was found to be
not consistent with the published data
so these two papers showed that between
80 and 90 percent of the projects where
they conducted in-house validation
studies
the published findings couldn't be
reproduced and there are many reasons
for which findings may not be reproduced
but things like poor experimental design
or non reporting that's not transparent
or reporting that's not complete have
been flagged as concerns
so we've conducted a survey looking at
the quality of published animal research
so we looked at publicly funded animal
research in the us and the uk
and experiments using mice rats and
non-human primates across all research
areas
so this project was funded by the
medical research council
and it was published in 2009 and so it
we identified key areas for improvement
and experimental design analysis and
reporting
so for example very few papers reported
the use of randomization and blinding
and none of the papers discussed how the
sample size was chosen
when we looked at the statistical
analysis reporting we found only 70
of the papers described the methods used
and presented the results with a measure
of precision or variability such as a
standard deviation
so that means a third of the studies
were lacking the minimum information
required to understand the results
and then looking at that we after
looking at that we looked at the type of
information included in the papers so
a whole range of things like how the
experiments were described how the
animals used were described
we found for example that one quarter of
the studies reported
neither the weight nor the age of the
animals being used so the survey really
identified
scope for improvement in the way animal
research is conducted and reported
and these findings are not isolated and
virtually every study that's looked at
the quality of animal research has found
quality wanting
and there hasn't been a lot of
improvement in the last 10 years
so this study published more recently
from malcolm mcleod's group in edinburgh
was looking at um highlighting how
information allowing readers to assess
how reliable the results are likely to
be is frequently missing from
publication so it's looking at some of
the same things
that our previously published survey
looked at so in panel a we have a
frequency of reporting randomization
panel b blinded assessment of outcome
and panel c
sample size calculation and this was
designed done across
different disease areas for in vivo
research and then the bottom right is a
list of the disease areas and on the
graphs they go on the x-axis from left
to right in that same order
and you can see that in panel a with
randomization although it did vary
across disease areas on average about a
quarter of the paper's
reported randomization and in panel b
although it did vary across disease
areas again
just under a third on average reported
blinding in the research publications
and you can see in panel c sample size
calculation that is quite consistent
across the board and less than one
percent of the papers studied
showed any justification for the numbers
of animal used
and you might think this depends on
where you publish and that papers and
high impact factor journals will publish
more rigorous science
but their study also looked at this and
they found that it doesn't make a
difference so if we look here panel a
again is looking at randomization panel
b
at blinded assessment of outcome and
panel c sample size calculation
and as before the percentage of papers
reporting these are on the y
axis but on the x axis here we have
deciles of journal impact factor so it's
increasing
from left to right and you can see that
there's no correlation between
the higher impact factor journals and
higher reporting of measures of rigor
so this really highlights the problem
with the reliability of animal research
and whether we can actually trust the
results that are being published in the
literature
and this is also an ethical problem
because if studies are not designed to
yield robust results
or if they're not reported properly then
it is a waste of animals
and it is an ethical issue but it can
also be an economic issue
so this paper was published a few years
ago and it looked at how much all of
this irreproducible research was costing
so the budget for pre-clinical research
is about 56 billion
a year in the us and they estimated in
this study that about
half of that was producing
irreproducible research
and then they looked at within the
irreproducible research
what were the categories of
irreproducibility and they found that
about half of that was down to the study
design
the analysis of the data or the
reporting and those are things that our
program of work at the nc3r specifically
focuses on
so the experimental design program at
the nc3rs aims to help researchers
improve the design of animal research
and its reporting in scientific
publications
so our perspective is that if studies
are not designed to yield reliable
results or if they're not reported in
enough detail
they can't add to the evidence base and
that means they're a waste of animals
so we've developed a number of resources
to help support scientists
in designing their experiments more
robustly and reporting them more
thoroughly
and today i'm going to talk to you about
the experimental design assistant
so the experimental design assistant or
eda is an online tool for researchers
to design and vivo experiments so it's
freely available
and it's available on eda.nc3rs.org.uk
and the eda is like having your own
personal statistical assistant
so it provides bespoke advice and
feedback on your experimental plans
it gives you recommendations on
statistical tests that are appropriate
for the design of your study
and it helps determine the most
appropriate sample size for your study
and provide dedicated support for
randomization and blinding
and you can produce a report to
summarize the key information in your
experimental design as a pdf
so in the eda each experimental plan is
represented as a diagram made up of
colored shapes called nodes
and each node represents a different
part of your experiment
so on the slide here we have a simple
two group comparison and i'm just going
to talk you through this diagram
so we start with a pool of animals and
the animals are allocated by complete
randomization into two groups
group one receives an injection of
vehicle and group two receives an
injection of a drug
and then we measure the plasma glucose
and all of the animals in our experiment
and the data collected so the plasma
glucose levels are used in the analysis
as well as the independent variable of
interest which in this case is whether
the animals received a vehicle or drug
so an eda diagram has three kind of main
types of information in it so in the
gray nodes in the top left here
we have high level information about the
experiment and the objectives and things
like that
in the blue and purple nodes here we
have the practical steps so these are
the things that you physically carry out
in the lab
and in the kind of green and maroon
color we have the analysis plan so
things are important when you're
analyzing your data
so the there is more information inside
each of these shapes
so for example in the group nodes you'll
have the number of animals per group
the number of experimental units per
group and justification for the sample
size
and then in the allocation node you'll
have more information about the
procedure for randomization so let's
have a look inside an allocation node
so we can see the randomization strategy
so you can select from your drop down
list in this case it's complete
randomization
but you can also name the randomization
procedure so that's how the random
sequence was generated so in this case a
spreadsheet generated by the eda
and you can see that there are other
fields inside the property of this note
so you can put more information inside
each of these shapes in the experiment
an eda diagram can be more explicit than
a narrative text description of an
experiment
because you've got more information
inside each of those components
and a good example of this is blinding
so often in a text description and
experiment you'll say the researchers
were blinded
but in an eda diagram you can say that
the researchers whether or not they were
blinded at the allocation stage
when you're taking the measurements and
during the analysis and not only whether
or not they were blinded but how that
blinding was carried out so for example
at the measurement stage
whether the animals coded or whether
somebody else took the measurements
who's not involved in the experiment so
you can be really explicit about what's
going on
and you can represent any experiment as
a diagram in the eda
and the diagrams are machine readable so
the system uses computer-based logical
reasoning to provide feedback
so some examples of the feedback include
this prompt which says
that the diagram does not include any
nuisance variables
so the prompt includes what a nuisance
variable is common types of nuisance
variables and animal experiments such as
baseline body weight or the day of the
experiment of this day-to-day
variability
and also how to use that variable in the
design and analysis of the experiment to
try and mitigate against the effects
another feedback prompt asks you to
clarify the blinding status when the
results are assessed
the prompt will explain why the blinding
is important different stages of the
experiment
during which you can be blinded and
different ways to blind different stages
of the experiment so you can decide not
only what is most appropriate for your
experiment
but what is actually feasible in the
facility or the laboratory that you're
working
so you can also use the eda to help
communicate your plans with others such
as an ethical review board or a funding
body
so the eda report was designed to help
researchers who are already entering
this information into the eda
to export key information at the click
of a button and use it to identify
this key information in the grant
application or ethical review process
so the report contains the objectives
and hypotheses of your experiment
the number and of animals you're using
and the justification for the sample
size
any steps you're taking to minimize bias
such as randomization and blinding
what your primary outcome is and
secondary outcomes if you're measuring
more than one outcome
and your plan statistical analysis
methods and then there's a summary of
the eda feedback that has not been
addressed
and an image of your eda diagram at the
end
so we've come up with this eda workflow
to help you get the most out of support
we provide in the eda
so what we suggest you do is you draw
your diagram and then you fill in the
information inside each
of the nodes so fill in the node
properties but if you're not sure what
to put in any of those fields then we
suggest that you leave it blank because
the eda can provide feedback to help you
decide what's most appropriate
so once you've had a first go at drawing
your diagram you can use the critique
function
and then it will give you some feedback
and you may go back and decide to redraw
parts of your diagram change it a bit
add more information in the node
properties now that you've read the
feedback
and then you can critique your diagram
again so you can repeat these first
three steps
as many times as you like until you're
happy with your experimental plan
then you can use the analysis suggestion
function and that will
recommend an analysis method that is
appropriate for the particular design
that you've put in the eda
and once you've done that you can use
the inbuilt power calculators to
determine the most appropriate sample
size
you can use the randomized allocation
report function to generate your
randomization sequence
and what this does is it generates a
randomization sequence taking into
account any blocking factors
and it generates that it's an excel
spreadsheet attached to an email
so the system will ask you to provide
the email address of the person who's
helping you with randomization and
blinding so the random allocation
sequence gets sent directly to them so
you can maintain
your blinding throughout the experiment
you can also share the experiment with
others so share your diagram with
colleagues and collaborators
and you can produce this um diagram
report the pdf we talked about in the
previous slide
and once you've carried out your
experiment you can go ahead and update
the diagram
so there are a couple of fields that are
specifically for once your drag
once your experiment has been finished
so for example in the group node there
is
a space to say the planned number of
experimental units
but also the actual number that you've
used so if you had some attrition during
the course of your experiment you could
record that
and that's really good because you can
hang on to that record of attrition
and then if you come to do a similar
study in the future you can look back
and you can go right okay i had 10
nutrition so you'll take that into
account in your next sample size
calculation
there's also more information on
experimental design on the eda website
so this covers concepts crucial to the
internal validity of your experiment
and how best to represent these in your
eda diagram
so an example of this is in our animal
characteristics page where we provide
guidance on how differences in animal
characteristics can influence the
experimental design used
so an example of this guidance is
regarding using both sexes and
experiments
so using both male and female animals in
an experiment enables the findings to be
generalized across the whole population
so you're not just restricted to one sex
but one of the reasons researchers don't
always do this is that they believe that
the variation in female
animals especially across the eastern
cycle can introduce extra variability
so this graph on this slide is plotting
the coefficient of variation for
different experiments from a
meta-analysis study
so this study looked at 293 articles
with behavioral morphological
physiological and molecular traits that
were monitored in male and female mice
and these female mice were tested
without regards to the estrous cycle so
they didn't control for that
and you can see that by plotting the
variability so towards the right hand
side of the x-axis means more
variability
and the data from the females is plotted
in red and the data from the males is
plotted in blue
and where they overlap it is purple and
you can see that the variability was not
greater than females than a male so
that's not a good reason
to not include females in your study so
this graph is from a different study
looking at sex bias and this time they
were looking at sex bias in pain
research
so the graph shows analysis of
preclinical studies published in the
journal pane
so the bar on the left covers research
published between 1996 and 2005.
and it shows that about 80 of the
studies in this period used
only males and then the other bars are
2015
16 17 18 and 19 across from left to
right
and it shows that there is over time the
male only studies have decreased as more
studies are conducted in either females
or
in both sexes and the studies including
both sexes are shown in this graph and
the three shades of purple
so these different shades represent how
the sex data were analyzed
so the darker purple where both sexes
were included but the sex differences
were not analyzed
and then the other two lighter shades of
purple indicate where sex differences
were looked for but either not
identified in the mid shade of purple
or a difference was reported in the
lightest shade of purple
so you can see that we are making
progress towards using both sexes
in our studies but there is still some
more work to be done
so it does make sense to include both
sexes in your study unless you are
studying a process like oogenesis that
does occur only in one sex
so using both sexes doesn't necessarily
mean you need to increase the total
number of animals in your experiment but
to ensure
that you have the same proportion of
males to females in each of your
experimental groups you should randomize
males and females separately to your
different intervention groups
and this prevents sex bias in those
groups
if you are using both sexes to make your
results more generalizable so you want
them to be generalizable across the
whole population
but you have good reason to believe that
you're not expecting a big difference
from males and females
then you don't need to increase the
total number of animals you're using
and you can determine the sample size by
powering for the biologically relevant
effect size of your main intervention
say your drug treatment
and use both sexes with preferably half
and half male and female in each group
and if you include sex and the analysis
is blocking factor
then this takes into account the
variability induced by sex
and increases your ability to detect a
real effect of that intervention
if you do want to compare male and
female animals to see if the
intervention affects them differently
you would design your study with two
factors of interest so the intervention
and sex and the number of animals you
need in your study depends on the
purpose and what comparisons
and which groups you're going to be
comparing afterwards
and so we do have some guidance on this
on our eda website
in the experimental design section and
the animal characteristics page
so why should you use the eda we believe
that using the eda
improves the reliability of your results
so it helps you address obvious sources
of bias
and this helps you address them while
you're planning your study so that means
that if you do
find a potential source of bias you can
do something about it and mitigate
against it so that you can fix it
before you've started your study so it's
not too late it can also help promote
better understanding of experimental
design
so raise awareness of why these things
are important so every time a user gets
feedback from the eda you learn
something new
and the system is not a black box
telling you exactly what to do but it
does provide information about the
implications of doing things a certain
way
so you can understand what you're doing
and make informed choices
the eda can also facilitate peer review
or assessment of your experimental plans
because it's such an explicit
description
then it can be really transparent so
editors peer reviewers and readers
having access to your design and all the
information
have a really good idea of knowing
exactly what you're doing
and also it can form a sort of soft
pre-registration so it can provide
evidence that your study was planned
as you're reporting it and you haven't
for example change your primary outcome
measure after looking at the data and
this is because the eda
report the pdf report i talked about
earlier when you create that it has a
time stamp on it
and if you download that report and then
maybe put it on something like open
science framework or another data
repository
you'd also have an upload timestamp for
that as well so you could have two
kind of ways to prove that you have
planned your study as you are reporting
it
the eda can also promote more careful
consideration of your experimental plans
so we'd really want scientists to spend
more time planning their experiments
identifying their variables considering
the data you're going to be collecting
so we want scientists to spend more time
planning and thinking about things
before they've started the study so if
you discover potential problems you can
mitigate against them or you can fix
them
rather than completing the study
realizing afterwards that you've
introduced biases but there's nothing
you can do about it
and we also think the diagrams are
really useful to help discuss
your experimental plans and lab meetings
or workshops because having a visual
overview of your experiment
makes it easier to discuss the specific
thing you want help with
like for example figuring out how people
are going to help you with the blinding
or discussing which is the best
primary outcome measure for your
specific scientific question
so the eda helps you design your
experiments but if you want guidance
when planning how to breed your
experimental animals then the nc3 ounce
has breeding and colony management
guidance online as well
so the guidance has been produced by an
international working group of experts
in colony management and experimental
design
including experts from the jackson lab
in the us and the mary lyon
in the uk and the center for
phenogenomics
in canada so the information is
available as a web resource
that includes best practice for managing
your colony considerations when
archiving your lines
and tips for selecting a breeding
strategy for example the things
you need to watch out for that may be
affected by the genotype or the
time frame when your animals are needed
do you need a certain number of animals
um every six months for example
or do you need a whole lot of animals
all in one go
it also includes a frequently asked
questions page which includes a worked
example to calculate
reading numbers we also have an email
advice service for
very specific questions for example if
you're having trouble breeding a
difficult line then you can email us
and we can forward that on to the expert
working group to get some help
we are having a webinar on efficient
reading on the 1st of march 2021 and if
you are interested in joining us
you can go to nc3rs.org dot uk webinars
and you'll find a way to register there
so the eda helps you plan experiments
and the breeding and colony management
guidance helps you
plan the breeding of your experimental
cohorts but we developed the
arrive guidelines to improve the
reporting of information and animal
research publications
so the arrived guidelines were
originally published in 2010 and i've
been revised over the last few years and
the updated guidelines arrived 2.0 were
released in july last year
so the guidelines consist of a checklist
of items that have to be included in
their manuscript to ensure comprehensive
and transparent reporting
so the items in the arrive guidelines
are important for different reasons
so for internal validity for example
description of study design how the
animals were allocated to groups how the
sample size was chosen
so this is really crucial information to
understand how reliable and robust
those results are some of the items are
important to determine that
to ensure the paper has enough
information to repeat the studies that
are described
so comprehensive description of
experimental procedures
and description of the characteristics
of the animals in this study
and then some items provide information
about the context and scientific
relevance of the study
so for example the scientific background
any relevance to other species
and information about their ethical
approvals so the arrive guidelines apply
to all in vivo research so it doesn't
matter if the species used does not
require ethical approval the guidelines
are about rigorous science so that
applies to all
and vivo experiments in arrive 2.0 the
items are organized into two sets
so the arrive essential 10 is the
minimum requirement so this means the
basic minimum to include in a manuscript
because without this information
reviewers and readers can't confidently
assess the reliability of the findings
presented
and then there's a recommended set so
these items complement the essential 10
and add really important context to the
study and reporting all items in both
lists
represents best practice and we have
introduced a couple of new items so for
example protocol registration
so pre-registration is now standard
practice for clinical trials but it's
also emerging as a mechanism that's
likely to improve the transparency of
animal research
and for that reason protocol
registration is one of the new items
that we added to the newly revised
arrive guidelines
so protocols can be registered in a
registry but another option is via
registered reports
so registered reports is a publishing
format where you have peer review of the
study design including your analysis
plan
before you start your study so this
means that reviewers comments and
suggestions can be taken into account
before you begin the practical
experiments
and this can really help you make your
research stronger so after this initial
review called stage one review you get
in principle acceptance of your study
so this means you can publish your study
regardless of whether your results are
statistically significant or not so this
really encourages more rigorous study
design
and helps reduce publication bias and
the registered reports format is used by
over 250 journals including bmc biology
royal society open science and plus
biology and i've put a link
to the registered report website on this
page so if you'd like to learn more
about them you can
check them out there another important
initiative i'd like to highlight is
reproducibility
so reproducibility is a grassroots
initiative helping researchers discuss
issues papers and ideas about improving
science reproducibility and the open
science movement
so it's open to researchers in any field
and any career stage so anyone can get
involved and anyone is welcome to start
their own reproducibility club
so if you're interested in finding out
more their website is
reproducibility.org
and they have starter packs on the open
science framework and i've put a link on
the slide
to their open science framework
repository so the resources on osf
include reading lists to help you get
started and there is one tailored
specifically towards in vivo studies
so i'd just like to conclude by
highlighting the reach of arrive and eda
and so they are endorsed by many of the
major stakeholders in scientific
research
so for example the arrive guidelines are
endorsed by over 1 000 journals
so they're recommended in their
instructions to authors and many major
funding organizations recommend that
researchers use the eda
when preparing a grant application that
contains animal research
so that includes the mrc and the welcome
trust in the uk
but also funders in the in europe or the
us like the nih
there's also grassroots support from the
researchers themselves so the eda has
over
10 000 registered users and over the
past few years we have had over 40 000
requests for printed copies of the
arrive guidelines from 50 different
countries
so thank you very much for your
attention if you'd like more information
about the eda you can go to
eda.nc3rs.org
and if you'd like more information about
the arrive guidelines the website is
arriveguidelines.org
thank you